The
next
excerpt is taken from original tape to ninety nine.
I
play have
kids. And sometimes we play Calum and the trees follow the leader.
You
have hops that. God. Well
you know. We write the numbers down
to ten on the on the black the senior and here black.
And we draw the Ragon number
one and we will jump in number two or one foot up to ten and
jump back and stay in a one foot in pick the rock up and jump. And
if you can get the rock into Tim and do the saying you win the game.
Oh oh oh
yeah
we call it a we put our feet into the engine engine the
money. All you know.
We're we have put our feet in and listen in to Engine engine number
mass speeding down the Chicago land. If the train should jump the track. Do
you want your money back. Yes or no the some buy say yes or somebody else
and now they will say oh wow spell the word yes and you
are mad if so and one is not it is for.
Oh. This
is a pretty
good
job bro you know
what
the shameful thing.
Will sound. In the
valley where the green grass grow. They say wander the fleet and around. She's saying
she sang she sang so fully
along came John a just on a chilly many kisses did she
recently and this key jump an inter she made
a nest of matches that she was the.
One
person
we put our feet in the same bank and whoever is it will be
the last one this is they are beaten
and want to spin. And their kids
whole pad their face may be thin.
My mother told
me to wash them close are you ready if we now
are reading your teeth in the
saying that I was on your
way with their ready and then when he come looking for
us here for. First of all a saying the first one.
And if you cast the first one
this the first person that he catches it.
Yeah.
The
following lead
you.
See we can to leave
within two full where we want for the leader. So we are
to come back and like my cards and sure the lack of want to
lead on
time and you will do anything she do. We're going to
park and
play.
By
playing. And.
Grant. Nothing but sure.
And then just when we don't play them then playing
three
pairs to six gray.
Go. Why are you here.
To live like a book my teacher will let me do
you see
you know she holla at
me and when I be doing the work she'll say I wasn't
Don't she have seen me play new day and see me doing work and not
talking just
wander about talking. And she had this big take may in fact.
She hears all the train talk she Benjamin and
dad and I had jobs and I said I do
you scare me.
Well the player when
you think she will fail because she was telling us she used to tell us
right
from wrong. She was there because she knew
she was she did she want us
not she wanted us to behave ourselves when we can
be manageable to everyone.
We
went to Harpers Ferry all went to the Smithsonian.
And we went to the capital and Ronan's our way.
Out and go many to him
when
he. When I first came there we started.
Christopher Columbus and then we went
on and we studied about the
real
Lucian war and then we started back.
And we studied. John
Hancock and
Thomas Jefferson and A.
We started by most of the
press called them.
Right.
If
I am going to tell like my
homework. In there after I got
home. I could go out and play and I didn't have to look into T.V. so I didn't want
to
miss Mari.
Mari was a map on our part.
Because
I used to lunch with her every twelve
o'clock or.
She picked me.
But it wasn't only me in the lurch
with her. Other friends of mine so her claim.
We can actually if you tell
us not to be bad in
life and don't be angry. Don't be now don't
be a mammal.
And
doing things you do. Nuff Boston
to do you.
Don't want to go. Oh yeah thanks.
Like that. Of being born
is
good for you.
Like a Girl was in the store and you need to
say because you didn't have enough money and I will give less to send out the
call.